Вітаю! Мене звати Єгор Стадний.
Я заступник Міністра освіти і науки
України.
Карантин вніс зміни у навчальний
процес,але ЗНО відбудеться
за будь-яких обставин.
Якщо карантин завершується до початку
червня, основна сесія ЗНО відбудеться
між 25 червня та 17 липня.
Якщо карантин триватиме до початку
серпня, основна сесія ЗНО відбудеться
між 17 серпня та 4 вересня.
Чому ЗНО важливе?
По-перше, ЗНО не дозволить повернути
корупцію під час вступу.
По-друге, в умовах пандемії ЗНО
набагато безпечніше, ніж вступні іспити.
Минулого року на бакалаврат вступило
145 тисяч абітурієнтів.
Кожен із них подавав по кілька заяв.
Загалом – 900 тисяч заяв.
70% із них були подані до університетів
5 міст: Києва, Харкова, Львова, Дніпра
та Одеси.
Якби хтось наважився скасувати ЗНО,
сотні тисяч абітурієнтів
та їхніх батьків по кілька разів їздили
би в інші міста для складання вступних
іспитів.
Вони б у великій кількості збиралися
в аудиторіях.
А ЗНО – це 15 учасників плюс
2 інструктори в одній аудиторії та
щонайменше півтора метри
відстані між ними.
Тим паче ЗНО складають переважно
за місцем свого проживання.
Тому ЗНО відбудеться за будь-яких умов.
Ми дбаємо про безпеку та чесний і
прозорий вступ.
По-перше, продовжуйте готуватися до ЗНО.
Хтось самостійно, хтось на
онлайн-курсах. Також на Youtube-каналі МОН,
телеканалах «Рада» та «Київ»
щодня відбуваються уроки з підготовки
до ЗНО.
По-друге, оберіть якісну програму та
університет.
Вища освіта – це інвестиція вашого часу
та ресурсів у майбутнє, у якому у вас є
достаток та омріяна справа.
Обирайте університет, у якому сильні
викладачі, сильні студенти та
сприятливе середовище.
Одразу відкиньте ті заклади, в яких
дають і беруть хабарі.
Сильні викладачі – це ті, до яких
студенти самі хочуть іти на пари,
ті, які займаються дослідженнями, ті,
до яких приходять роботодавці,
коли їм потрібні нові працівники.
Шукайте університет зі сприятливим
середовищем.
Там ви зможете реалізувати студентські
проєкти, у вас буде справжня практика,
ви зможете самостійно обирати дисципліни
Правду про університет вам розкажуть
його студенти та випускники.
Знайдіть їх у соціальних мережах і
розпитайте про викладачів і умови
навчання.
І пам’ятайте!
Карантин – це не канікули.
Для випускників – це шанс краще
підготуватися та зробити усвідомлений
вибір своєї майбутньої професії.
Всі новини на Фейсбуці,
Телеграм-каналі та сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки.